hey what's going on it's Pilbara and
it's time for the Monday morning podcast
for Monday September 18 2017 what's
going on how are ya how's it going
everybody how are you starting a new
week get them out there put your pants
on one leg at a time Joe Sixpack going
to work I got to keep it down listen to
this this is the new more subdued
quieter podcast now that I have a baby
daughter I'm recording this Sunday night
and that's all you need to [ __ ] know
Mike [ __ ] do you hearing that I heard
some sort of weird noise there I don't
know what I did my [ __ ] mixer is
acting weird what happens if I push this
button
anything anything oh there you go just
goes into one speaker and then the other
one headphone and then the other how are
you did you enjoy your football Sunday
did you Julius sports weekend
did you follow politics did you watch
college football you just stare at the
wall drinking booze ignoring your loved
ones well if you did I'm jealous
Oh Billy no booze Billy what where Oh
tell me where'd your booze go Billy Boy
Billy Boy tell me where did your booze
go charming Billy it's sitting over
there and every night I [ __ ] stare
but I can't have a [ __ ] drop because
I got acting work yes I can't have a
[ __ ] drop because I got acting work
see I'm slowly losing my mind
what if I just said one Billy Boy Billy
Boy
what if you just had one charming Billy
well then I drink the whole bottle and
I'd [ __ ] puke in the couch and I be a
fat [ __ ] on camera and HD I'm down to
176 and change and having been working
out because I was playing catch and
[ __ ] up my [ __ ] calf that's how old
I am so I've just been eating like an
angel
you know after every bite I count night
you [ __ ] 27 times on each side of my
mouth and then I take the napkin and I
wipe off like a [ __ ] angel if there
is a God
a la whatever the [ __ ] peanut butter
sandwiches you're into remember that ah
la peanut butter sandwiches
I wonder [ __ ] the counts getting any
death threats from extreme Muslims
well maybe he was Muslim I don't know
they never really said God knows Sesame
Street was liberal enough they probably
would have thrown that in back then
right and then Bob would be [ __ ]
singing that song what is it who are the
people in your neighborhood in your
neighborhood in your neighborhood Oh who
are the people in your neighborhood the
people that you meet each day Oh [ __ ]
puppet vampire that happens be Muslim is
in your neighborhood just too long
that's what it was too [ __ ] long you
have an ad haven't had rubber booze in
[ __ ] in 32 days 32 [ __ ] goddamn
days I'll tell you right now I'm not
gonna lie to you this was the longest
month in a day of the year without a
doubt it's fun in the morning it's not
in the evening like right now I just
want to get [ __ ] blasted you know I
don't know I can't do it though can't do
it gradually coming down I got to get
down to a buck 72 my fighting weight his
bob Pogo says on efforts for family
season two while you're watching are you
liking are you giving it a thumbs up
whatever the [ __ ] scoring system is
over there at Netflix you know I don't
know what they use it now and I think
they said they're gonna go with thumbs
up thumbs down and I think they stuck
with the star system I have no idea I I
don't pretend to know my whole [ __ ]
weekend has just been about keeping my
[ __ ] leg raised I went to this
[ __ ] potty on Thursday night with my
lovely wife and the [ __ ] host of it
was given a big speech and I was stoned
sober and I had to go over and sit in
the corner was outside on this guy's
lawn with like a tent right and I'm
sitting I go off in the corner to sit
down stone sober with a [ __ ] I had
like club soda and lime the hardest
thing for me to order cuz I can never
remember what you say I could just
I can never remember club soda because I
never water it and after time I go up to
the bartender the beer what can I get
you I'm like what's that thing people
drink when they don't drink and then
they go club soda I go yes with a lime
I'm not even trying to be funny
like a third of the time that's how I
have to order because I can't remember
what it is because I never ordered so
I'm on my second club soda in lime in
this guy who's hosting the party
fabulous host he's [ __ ] thanking all
these people I had to go outside the
tent because I see a stone wall where I
can sit down because my [ __ ] ankle is
filling up with fluid and it's becoming
twice the size my other ankle but you
know I went to the you know I just went
into some walk-in clinic and the guy
looked at it God huh tell you what I'll
tell you I can tell you what you did
right now I can tell you from across the
[ __ ] room without even doing an x-ray
you know walk-in clinic type [ __ ] you
know so I go to sit down the guys in the
middle of this great speech everybody's
[ __ ] listening and I don't know how I
set my glass down and I reached back to
get something I knocked it off and it
made that and it was like a [ __ ] wine
glass so it sounded like a booze glass
in the middle of his speech and like
half the 10th [ __ ] looks over at me I
spilt it on my leg I did all of this
stone sober so my laugh comes walking
out she's laughing at me going what did
you do and I was all embarrassed going I
was going Mia stop making a scene like I
felt bad enough as it was and then she
got mad at me cuz I got like I got you
know I got emotional with her so she
didn't talk to me for like two [ __ ]
days because of that but two [ __ ]
days she's not talking to me you know I
mean like if she ever spilt a drink on
herself and half 1/10 of people looked
over at her and I walked over and said
like what did you do you know mad she'd
be at me but that's how it works in the
male-female dynamic all right you're
either wrong or you were too mean when
you were right that's basically how it
was that's what it was I think I was
guilty of being too mean so anyways I I
watched a little bit of the Patriots
today I saw the first quarter I taped
the game I'm gonna watch the rest of it
Patriot's looked a little bit better
today obviously it's early in the season
you know this is what they always do
they hype up [ __ ] because people who
went beating teams are losing two teams
and all this [ __ ] that you're not gonna
see in January who gives a [ __ ] right
that's just getting going and I actually
went to I went to the StubHub Senate
today and I saw the new Los Angeles
chargers their first game against the
Miami Dolphins I went down there I got
to tell you that might be the best
stadium I've seen a football game and at
the NFL level simply because there was
only 25,000 people there I can't believe
the Patriots are playing the charges on
the road if I could see Tom Brady in a
25,000 seat stadium that'd be [ __ ]
incredible that's like old that's like
what the old NFL used to look like back
before you know we out [ __ ] all of
those other stadiums back before Lady
Gaga and [ __ ] Whitney Houston and
everybody brought all these other people
into the game all these people who are
just like oh my god what else happens
after the concert you know they started
watching football so they had to build
50 60 70 80 90 thousand [ __ ] seat
stadiums 25 thousand seat seats I got to
see two wily veterans two gunslingers
Phillip Rivers Phillip Rivers against
what's-his-face said Jay Cutler's a
junior Jake Jay Cutler that's right Jay
Cutler right am I gonna say his name
right Jay cutlet I like it one guy's a
[ __ ] religious freak with 90 kids the
other guys like set him up set him up
let's have another drink all right Jay
Cutler there you go that's right Jay
Cutler so [ __ ] San Diego I had the
goddamn game one weight this is showing
me a bodybuilder is it Jake this is the
age I'm at now I don't know anybody's
[ __ ] name anymore Jay Cutler there we
go or are we know it is Jay Cutler all
right whatever the [ __ ] this [ __ ] guy
right he leads his team down the field
they go ahead by three points and then
San Diego comes down the field Philip
Rivers he doesn't give a [ __ ]
you think he's worried about a [ __ ]
two
offense this guy's got nine miles to
feet you bet you haven't nine kids just
it's key just come home to a standing
ovation everybody's freaking is you have
a crowd you have a [ __ ] crowd of kids
how amazing is that until they all
become teenagers and then there's a ten
to fifteen year period where they hated
you you know you never made sure that
stake dad you always sat down the other
end of the table I wanted to sit closer
to you I think he's gonna deal with all
of that [ __ ] right was a great game
fantastic [ __ ] stadium that Gretton
is not a bad seat in the house I'm
telling you before they move to some
giant monstrosity of a [ __ ] stadium
that they're sharing with the Rams I
believe and it's gonna [ __ ] you know
bankrupt a city before they [ __ ] do
that if you get a chance definitely go
to this stuff up Center it's [ __ ]
phenomenal you know it's funny I was
upset and I was watching the game and I
see this guy flying over in this
helicopter the Robinson 44 during a
[ __ ] game
he looks like he's not even 500 feet off
the [ __ ] graph flies right over the
[ __ ] stadium and I with my limited
knowledge of aviation realized that when
there's a big event like that it's an
automatic temporary no-fly zone an hour
before in an hour and after the game I
believe that what is if not two hours
before and after right this [ __ ]
jerk-off flies right over the [ __ ]
stadium I'm sitting there with my buddy
going that didn't look like a cop right
you can't I don't think he can [ __ ]
do that
I'm just a novice but I do not think you
could do that this [ __ ] jerk-off
comes by again he's on his side showing
all the passengers down in it and then
like two seconds later like a police
helicopter comes flying over I don't
know if he got in trouble or what but I
don't know I know some pilots this is
this [ __ ] I like I said I don't ever
pretend to know anything about that
stuff as far as my limited knowledge you
were not allowed to do that
god forbid something happens and then
you [ __ ] land on 25,000 people
watching [ __ ] Jay Cutler right what
keg booze coming out of his pores going
up against the other guy from Ash
Wednesday right these Kansas City
chase Ferriero so I I [ __ ] got a taxi
on the way down and then on the way back
I called the car service and I'm [ __ ]
telling this guy I'm like meet me at 180
for an Avalon all right there's a
Kentucky Fried Chicken right next to a
donut place can you [ __ ] meet me
there right so the guy is like yeah all
right great great right so we get down
there right the game ends I walk out
there for 15 he's supposed to pick me up
at 4:30 I call the guy up he's like a
[ __ ] city block away everything's
going good then all of a sudden the cops
are everything and they're like they're
like uber and lyft 192 walk down walk
down - 192
right and I'm sitting there going well
I'm not who Boro lifts car service I'm
like these guys are gonna [ __ ] with me
so I try and call this guy I call the
guy up and I keep telling the guy he's
going ok I'm a block away and I'm going
yes yeah forget it oh the Kentucky KFC
I'm gonna no no no no no KFC no no KFC
there's a donut shop right next door I'm
gonna walk over see if you can turn in
there and he goes okay I'm gonna no no
listen I'm walking over I'm walking over
alright forget it you can't walk into
the donut place I'm gonna go down to 192
in Avalon he goes okay give me a parking
lot KFC he just kept saying that like a
prank show and I'm literally getting
angry yelling no 192 and Avalon into my
phone and like people with kids who turn
around looking at me so I'm trying to
put more of a happier tone in my voice
and it's just not working and he just
kept going okay KFC Park canonical no
192 and Avalon and then I finally go to
just repeat it repeat it he goes yes yes
I go repeat what I said he goes 192
Evelyn I go fine fine and then like he
calls me back okay we're gonna do the
doughnut shop and I'm gone I finally had
to [ __ ] take a picture of 192 in
Avalon and send it to the [ __ ] and he
showed up right and he was the greatest
guy ever greatest guy ever and I was
like guy you know what maybe I got a
little emotional
okay there's 25,000 people walking up
and down the goddamn Street here I don't
know what
do hear maybe you know I don't know what
but I will tell you that when I was at
the game kind of see when I was at the
game the these people in front of me
I've never seen this before we're
drinking
what's that Mexican beer that begins
with a with an M begins with an M a it's
in a it's [ __ ] gold right it looks
like it looks like a trophy looks
delicious especially after 32 days and
not booze and so these people in front
of me a drinking this [ __ ] in it out of
a can and they had this this [ __ ] on top
I'm like what the [ __ ] is that
I said crushed red pepper flakes what is
and this guy next to me goes chili
powder they put chili powder around the
top because I don't like it I'm like is
that like white people putting a lime in
a [ __ ] Corona I goes yeah it's
something like that he goes you know I
don't really like it I was like well I
got to try that I mean not right now but
eventually I'm gonna try that it looked
like the [ __ ] that you put on you know
there are the warning tracks of these
new baseball stadiums that's sort of
sand it's sort of rubber that sort of
look like [ __ ] far away so that guy
proceeds to get absolutely plastered and
after three [ __ ] quarters he comes
back up and yells to the crowd that they
stopped serving beer at the start of the
fourth quarter and he's yelling about
how dumb it is and that's one of those
moments were as good that I also wasn't
drunk cuz I would have been like yeah
buddy you're the reason you're the
[ __ ] reason they do that because you
can't hold your alcohol look at you
you're a [ __ ] mess so I actually went
to this game and this is like a record
for me I didn't have any booze I didn't
eat any of the [ __ ] food I had like two
handfuls of [ __ ] peanuts and drank
like three water's that's it because I
can't be a fat [ __ ] this thing you
know so I [ __ ] go downstairs to take
a piss right and there's this [ __ ]
guy just yelling at the police and
there's like two cops there and then
there's three and then there's five and
I'm walking by I go down I take a piss
and I come back and there is like half
the police forces standing there and is
this white dude screaming at all of
these cops
screaming you got to do some go up there
and do something another white guys yell
I do he was like total white guy moment
like yelling at [ __ ] 20 cops he's not
getting the [ __ ] kicked out of him and
they actually listen to him hey wait up
they kick two guys out the other guys
were like really [ __ ] like oh alright
they just sort of left I don't know what
they did I don't know what the [ __ ] they
did it was the weirdest thing was the
two guys screaming looking like the ones
that were gonna get [ __ ] arrested
like we're demanding that these cops go
up and do something and then they
finally [ __ ] did and they threw these
guys out it's a really bizarre day but
once again a phenomenal [ __ ] sports
experience if you go there so I
apologize a lot of this [ __ ] is gonna be
all sports stuff that's kind of what I
did this weekend I cut on with my
daughter and I just watched a bunch of
sports and did anybody put on the NFL
Network and watch Dan Marino a football
life it was [ __ ] amazing but like you
can't do the Dan Marino story and
[ __ ] thirty minutes that should have
been an hour and a half long at least
and as much as he feel like he finally
got his [ __ ] do as you're watching
Troy Aikman Peyton Manning Brett Favre
all of him saying this was the guy this
was the [ __ ] guy then finally putting
to bed this whole thing that you know
that because he didn't win a Super Bowl
like that's some sort of like black mark
up against the guy's [ __ ] name the guy
he was so ahead of his time he was such
an unbelievable [ __ ] quarterback it
took 25 years a quarter of a century and
a massive change in the rules of passing
in how you could defend against the past
for people to start [ __ ] with what
this guy did from 1983 on he was
unbelievable kills me his dad taught him
how to throw ball come the arm comes up
ball comes out and I can't even tell you
how many times as a Patriots fan we
played him twice a [ __ ] year I
thought Andre tip had had him he's armed
with the football would still be at his
waist and Andre was bringing his [ __ ]
arm down to get him and somehow his
armored come up and it'd be out
40-yard [ __ ] laser oh my god he used
to kill us he used to kill for all you
young dolphin fans out there that
[ __ ] hate Tom Brady you know because
he's been beating your ass two games a
year for like almost his whole career
just about that's payback for Dan Marino
I'm telling you Dan Marino today in his
prime would easily throw for over six
thousand yards easily and if you could
actually win without having a running
game which you can nowadays the way that
[ __ ] game has changed he would have
at least one Super Bowl ring okay I'm
telling you one of my favorites of
[ __ ] all-time and I'm glad they
finally did the football life and I
think it was at least an hour too short
all right there you go I've said my
piece that's coming from a Patriots fan
too and when he played I [ __ ] hated
him because he he killed us I didn't
really hate him but you know what I mean
I wasn't pleased with him alright let me
do a little bit of the something has to
break up this sport stop guys I gotta I
gotta do the [ __ ] I gotta do the
reads here alright oh Jesus oh here we
go oh the unholy matrimony of sports and
gambling it's not even unholy man it's
just always been there and I'm glad that
the NFL is finally [ __ ] addressed it
finally addressed their fan base you
know we like football
we like tits and ass and we like to you
know [ __ ] with our mortgage payment
every month alright draftkings everybody
fantasy football season is almost here
how old is this copy it is here and
there's no better way to get closer to
the game you love them with draft kings
one-week fantasy football draft kings is
hosting a $100,000 contest that is
totally free to enter and if you draft
the perfect lineup you could you can win
1 billion dollars with draft kit you can
well you can basically win what Netflix
earns in a month is that incredible 1
billion dollars you could actually
finance a month of war with draft kings
there before taxes after that you could
you can finance a conflict with draft
kings there are many ways
to play choose between public contests
with big cash prizes go against the big
boys here or private contests where you
can compete against a group of your
friends draftkings also has beginner in
casual casual contests will you play
against people of a similar skill level
the best part is you get to draft
everybody up that level is wearing
sandals
you know let's try to break you so
people don't get low self-esteem here
the best part is you get to draft a new
team each week without any commitment so
get to draftkings.com now and use promo
code Burpee you are our to play in
draftkings free week one contest what
the [ __ ] why am i reading this with a
hundred thousand dollars you can still
try to win a billion right whatever just
go play [ __ ] draftkings alright promo
code bar at draft kings.com
eligibility restrictions applied which
judging from that pass means their
employees can't play anymore see draft
kings.com for details on oh they used to
play the other one i think all right
everybody it's helix alex you know
something there are a ton of online
mattress retailers popping up these days
all with a one-size-fits-all solution to
a better sleep you know what i had no
idea i do not have my ear to the ground
in the [ __ ] mattress retail i didn't
realize it was a whole bunch of these
people popping up oh my god if there's
another online mattress retailer guess
what one size doesn't fit all
alright helix sleep offers something
that doesn't exist anywhere else a
mattress personalized to your unique
preferences and sleeping style that
won't set you back thousands of dollar
dollars go to hellix sleep calm slash
bar take their simple two to three
minutes sleep quiz they'll build a
custom mattress that will be the best
thing that you've ever slept on
non-living i should say for couples
they've even personalized each side of
the mattress the beginning of the end of
the relationship everyone from GQ to
Cosmopolitan to the New York Times are
all talking about HELOCs sleep and once
you try it out you'll know why your
custom mattress arrives direct to your
door and a weekend shipping is
completely free try it for a hundred
nights gross if you don't love it
they'll pick it up
Oh Sandra fund you in full Jesus Christ
did they take you to a sperm donor place
and wring it out that's how they make
that money back in the [ __ ] shipping
all right go take goat a Hilux sleep
calm / burr right now and you get $50
towards your custom mattress that's
helic sleep calm / / for $50 off your
order
hey Hilux sleep calm / / alright what do
we got left here it's [ __ ] three more
oh look who's here
oh do me on DS me on DS yelling at a
bunch of cops doo doo doo doo biondi's
me undies they won't arrest me even
though I'm a [ __ ] but I'm white enough
they don't give a [ __ ] that's knowing
everybody else out cuz I am white yeah
my balls feel good in my privileged
underwear don't forget about the taint
sorry and I apologize to all Italian
Americans offended by that with the
without papers do you know I learned a
an Irish [ __ ] I'd never heard of which
was Nina
so Italians that was without papers in
India India and [ __ ] Irish Nina was
no Irish need apply I didn't know that I
had no [ __ ] idea this is back in like
the gangs in New York if you're actually
offended by that you better be 100%
Italian alright okay don't come at me
with your 15 percent being 100 percent
offended okay I'll send you some [ __ ]
pearl flowers alright me undies me
undies will be the most comfortable
underwear pair of underwear you will
ever own made from a sustainably sourced
natural soft fabric that's three times
softer than cotton what they do is they
punch a horse in the head and they cut
off its muzzle and then they put it
right down here where yet junk is you
know and then the horse wakes up
permanently smiling for the rest of its
life that's where the others where it
comes from a lot of people don't know
that that's what Modell is I mean what
else could be softer than cotton other
than a horse's muzzle I'm sorry for that
image
okay ultimate feel-good undies for when
you want to feel naked not and not be
naked for the fellas me on DS diamond
seam pouch lack
Oh bag I almost forgot the the the words
there this pouch the Freddie Mercury
themed pouch cradles your jewels and
gives you a so K mustache and leather
hat not included and gives your stuff
the support it needs without feeling too
tight right now ladies you will love the
soft eco-friendly fabric who would have
thought your [ __ ] could actually help
the environment so soft and touchable
100% satisfaction guaranteed they
guaranteed you will love your undies or
your money back right now me undies has
an exclusive offer for just my listeners
get 20% off your first pair and free
shipping and me undies is so sure you
will love their underwear they even
offer a 100% satisfaction guarantee you
order a pair and if you don't love your
first pair get a full refund this is a
no-brainer to try 20% off free shipping
on a percent satisfaction guarantee what
in God's name are you waiting for it to
get your 20% off free shipping in their
one percent satisfaction guarantee and
get the best softest underwear you will
ever own go to me undies talk comm / /
that's Muniz dot-com / birth this is a
limited time offer so what are you
waiting for start wearing the best
underwear of your life it changed my
life according to the copy it's time to
let me undies change yours go to me
undies calm / burr right now here's a
new category I wanted to start and I
should really [ __ ] know this guy's
name I want to start a new thing to
write in okay so this podcast doesn't
get any more stale than it already is is
your favorite performances by non stars
in movies where you and your friends
still quote it it's an unknown [ __ ]
actor and you may never even saw him
again never even seen the person again
so me I'm gonna kick it off I don't even
know this actress names let me look this
up he was in Reservoir Dogs cop buddy
actor see if I could find the name of
this guy
I don't know what this [ __ ] guy's
name is I got to give him a shot oh you
know I'm gonna hit pause because I want
to give this guy's a shout-out okay
unknown unheralded unheralded actor as
far as I know rich Turner in Reservoir
Dogs it's one of my favorite [ __ ]
just one Scene actors I don't know I
don't watch a ton of movies but I
[ __ ] love this guy he plays the cop
in the bathroom when what's-his-face Tim
Roth is sitting there with all the drugs
and he comes out there's a dog's dog
sniffing the drug sniffing dog sniffing
drug sniffing dog he was in Pulp Fiction
too meaning also yeah he wasn't in a lot
of movies but he plays Mike in the way
he he's being the cop and he's telling
that story just the way he liked the
line I said buddy I'm gonna shoot you in
the face if you don't put your [ __ ]
hands on that dashboard that's just the
way it's written in the way he did it he
goes I said buddy I am gonna shoot you
in the face if you don't put your
[ __ ] hands in that dashboard just the
way he said it I don't know why that
sounds exactly like a [ __ ] cop to me
so that was like something just me and
my friends we would be [ __ ] hammered
striking out with chicks and you just be
walking out to your car and one of you
invariably would just go buddy
I am gonna shoot you in the face and
everyone just start laughing you know
put your [ __ ] hands in that dashboard
who are your favorites who are your
favorites they just had that one thing
your [ __ ] friends you still quoted a
nice new a bunch of those there's
obviously a zillion guys there's a
zillion lines and [ __ ] pulp and sir
in Goodfellas by the way
rest in peace Frank Vincent the first
big guy to go from Goodfellas man I mean
what what an absolute legend what an
absolute legend he was as amazing as an
actor as his hair was what a head of
hair that guy had good Lord Jesus cry
what a head of hair that guy had his
whole friggin life that's what you say
when you bald you [ __ ] see that on
people look at that guy I don't know if
I ever had that hair some people you
know some people they just [ __ ] I
don't know what jeans that guy is that
guy he must had a Roman Emperor or
something in his [ __ ] family tree
credible actor and so goddamn funny
comedic timing was incredible I even
loved that commercial he did well I
think his only line was oh when that guy
was like stocking up the freezer he was
disrespected I'm his buddy just kept
going oh definitely gonna miss him and
that was definitely somebody on my
bucket list you know I get a movie I
have like [ __ ] two three lines but
like that was definitely a bucket list
to ever be able to do a scene with him
and what was so cool Michael Rapaport
quite possibly the funniest guy in
social media right now this [ __ ]
videos I was so goddamn funny he
actually posted a picture on his Twitter
account you should check it out I think
it's I am at I am Rapoport and it's him
working with Frank Vincent in the early
90s it was like really early on and he
got a picture of him shine in Frank
Vincent's shoes and he said at one time
Frank Vincent made me go home and get my
shine box and what I loved was a lot of
people now can look back and own it a
classic and everybody's quoted it a
zillion times but Rapoport already knew
go home and get your [ __ ] shine box
he was on that [ __ ] early [ __ ] early
90s
they've barely done editing it he
already knew that that was an instant
[ __ ] classic I got to get him back on
the podcast again he has so many amazing
stories anyways let's get Bellamy finish
this fire guy to break up the podcast I
mean the advertising ring why do I say
the wrong thing first before I correct
it I don't know bill cuz you dumb cuz
you have a zillion things on your mind
yeah fair enough
all right Dollar Shave Club everybody
what you might not know there's a lot of
things you do know but what you might
not know I said buddy is that Dollar
Shave Club also also has products for
pretty much everything else you need in
the bathroom body wash shampoo hair gel
don't need any of that lip balm
everything where am I going to mousse my
pubes at the store there are too many
options and you can't tell the
difference between any of them then if
you have any questions that clerk
usually doesn't know the difference or
is still running the [ __ ] cash
register they can't help you anyways
right
well Dollar Shave Club makes it easy and
convenient for you to upgrade your shave
and your bathroom
sorry the hiccups all of a sudden now
you don't have to step foot in a store
to get high-quality shave and grooming
products this is right here why I would
never invest in a [ __ ] strip mall I
swear to god I don't know what's gonna I
know where these kids are gonna meet you
know to get away from their [ __ ]
parents when all the malls go away and
everybody's just getting this [ __ ]
delivered by drones now you don't have
to step foot no [ __ ] mall right
Dollar Shave Club delivers them right to
your door just like their raises
everything is super high-quality and
will leave you looking and feeling
amazing from premium ingredients to
sophisticated sense Dollar Shave club's
is changing the game if you're sick of
the nonsense at the store now's the time
to try out dollar shave club for a
limited time Dollar Shave Club is
basically giving away their [ __ ] shower
shave starter set two new members for
only five bucks this starter set
features their executive razor and three
trial size versions of their most
popular products that help you stay
fresh and clean how much are the
heterosexual women of the world loving
that they're doing this ladies if you
guys stinks just buy them the [ __ ]
shower shave packet for Christmas and
stuff in the stocking with a cute little
note that says take a hint and you draw
a little smiley face in your first box
you will receive their shave butter body
wash and one white chewy butt wipes you
will also receive their executive razor
which includes their premium weighty
weighty
handle and a full cassette of cartridges
after the first box replacement
cartridges are sent for only a few bucks
a month this offer is exclusively
available at dollarshaveclub.com / /
that's dollarshaveclub.com / / dollars
shaped clubs high quality products will
have you covered from face to cheek to
butt cheeks from face cheeks to butt
cheeks i [ __ ] up that joke every week
there's no better time to try the club
and lastly but certainly not least lee
the classic the robert de niro the
original the Pacino the Marlon Brent
stamps.com everybody stamp save you time
and I save you money which you can use
to grow your business I can mail any
letter package trying to be interesting
with my line reads like that guy buddy I
will shoot you any package I'm gonna
read the next [ __ ] sentence the way he
broke that up let me just finish this
one first any package using my computer
and printer and the mailman to pick it
up a right boy the hassle the post
office and mail let me think the
postcode I can't still can't do it
doesn't know the rhythm and everything
from postcards to envelopes to packages
domestic and or international create
your stamps account and minutes online
with no equipment to lease and no
long-term commitments stamps com will
even help you decide the best class of
mail or your based on your needs no need
to lease an expensive postage meter I
use stamps calm whenever I send out my
posters guys we've got a [ __ ] myself
out if the NY shows for a couple of
bucks I'm a [ __ ] if I can figure out so
can you and right now you too can enjoy
stamps calm service with a special offer
that includes a four week trial plus
postage and a digital scale without long
term commitments go to stamp stop clip
on the microphone at the top of the
homepage and type in birbee you are our
that stamps.com in tuber all right all
right well let's get back to what the
[ __ ] okay formula what did you think I
was gonna talk about formula 1 what do
you think I was going to talk about how
Mississippi Mississippi State [ __ ]
trout's my LSU Tigers you know another
one of my favorite teams SMU giving away
pounds per player and the [ __ ]
offensive and defensive line against ACU
come on frogs now SMU was whipping that
[ __ ] horn toned ass for [ __ ] the
first half before they wore him down
they just leaned on do you think I was
gonna congratulate the Cleveland Indians
and an unprecedent 22 in a row is that
what you thought I was going to do you
think I was gonna do all of that and I
was going to talk about that Formula One
race down and [ __ ] Singapore that
race made me sick it's one of my
favorite races of the year it's at night
it's in Singapore it's one of the most
beautiful amazing / kind of freaked me
out cities I've ever been to in my life
/ countries it really is one of the most
beautiful like amazing [ __ ] city
where you just feel like you're
overbearing parents are home all the
time
it was [ __ ] rain it was night it was
raining out okay the Ferraris were
running great Daniel Ricciardo was
running great Mercedes wasn't doing that
well you know I know if Hamilton had a
[ __ ] I thought it was all tied up
maybe he was up by three points I can't
remember the Ferrari needed to show up
on this [ __ ] day all right
and if you watched when they were doing
the time trials on Saturday and you saw
what was like trying to drive behind
somebody doing 100 50 60 70 80 [ __ ]
miles an hour with that [ __ ] rooster
tail of water coming up I mean it was
gonna be an unbelievable [ __ ] race
God knows whoever's in [ __ ] first
place and then the first turn is gonna
win the goddamn race alright so
Sebastian Vettel the Ferraris they get
first and third alright with Daniel
Ricciardo on the Red Bull is in second
[ __ ] place I believe that's the way
it was right [ __ ] Mercedes are back
in fourth and fifth so the goddamn race
starts all Ferrari has to do all these
got to do is just make it to the first
turn in first [ __ ] place unscathed
he's gonna win this [ __ ] race okay
worst-case scenario Hamilton gets
[ __ ] second place that's only 18
points Vettel's gonna get 25
he'll pick up [ __ ] you know whatever
what is that seven points the [ __ ]
race starts Kimi räikkönen he acted like
[ __ ] Greg Brady when when he when the
pressure was on to beat him gotta beat
Marcia gotta get close to that quarter
of an inch he [ __ ] stomps on the gas
tries to go around oh I'm sorry it was
max Verstappen
not Daniel Carr tries to go around the
guy that [ __ ] tires get all [ __ ]
in a lock there and they [ __ ] go up
and over he [ __ ] [ __ ] up his car
slams the [ __ ] red bull car into his
[ __ ] teammate the other Ferrari
Vettel makes it to the first turn
unscathed meanwhile [ __ ] not on skate
but he makes it there but he thinks cars
[ __ ] up it got hit in the back
meanwhile [ __ ] Louise [ __ ]
Hamilton he drives right around the
shitty raisi sneaking by [ __ ] comes
back in with his [ __ ] up car Greg
Brady right smashes in to the [ __ ]
redbull guy again and who does he hit he
hits the [ __ ] Alfonso in the [ __ ]
orange car trying to do the exact same
thing as Lewis Hamilton but Lewis
Hamilton's the Derek Jeter [ __ ] star
child just blasts 3000 hit he hit a
[ __ ] Grand Slam one of these guys the
[ __ ] Vettel drives like you know two
more turns in the whole front of his car
comes off both Ferraris out of the
[ __ ] race they were in first in third
place are first and fourth that can I
don't remember they had him they had him
and they laughs they were both out of
the race before it even [ __ ] started
and all I could think is what my dad
used to always saying when somebody
would do something like that you'd be on
crisis [ __ ] way that guy Christ that guy
he could [ __ ] up a free lunch that's the
first expression that popped in my head
I think I tweeted it I was so [ __ ]
pissed
Ferrari could [ __ ] up a free lunch I
mean that was a free lunch
no-one could drive fast that day
Mercedes weren't running well the whole
[ __ ] weekend so what do you do you
take out yourself
and your [ __ ] teammate you clear out
the whole front
front row so [ __ ] Lewis Hamilton who
just drives along unscathed that guy
Lewis Hamilton is a blessed man that's
one of those deals he's one of those
guys makes you believe in a higher power
like this just somebody that just
[ __ ] loves I mean I'm taking away all
the preparation the man does but you
know he cuts around the outside no
problem Alfonso goes through the same
thing his [ __ ] days over unbelievable
and then the rest of the race then
riding around the [ __ ] rain in
Hamilton [ __ ] wins no problem
un-fuckin'-believable they I wanted to
see a race I knew that Hamilton was
gonna try to [ __ ] he was gonna be
happy sitting in you know all the way
back there right who would be right I
want to see what the [ __ ] he was gonna
do with his car not doing that well in
all of that rain would he actually crash
I mean you know he's gonna push it to
the [ __ ] limit all of that was out
the second it started like we're that
year the Jets were supposed to be good
and like [ __ ] 99 and like the first
game Vinny Testaverde goes back and
blows out his Achilles and then Keyshawn
was crying after the game that was the
original that's my quarterback that was
the original that's what it was like I
still watch the [ __ ] race it was
still [ __ ] it was still exciting but
Jesus Christ anyways and then I also I
watched the boxing that's all I did this
weekend is I just [ __ ] watched I'm
writing an episode of f is for family so
I just stayed in the whole [ __ ]
weekend when it wasn't writing I was
just watching sports and I'm not a big
boxing guy just because I've gotten
[ __ ] over so many times in the
pay-per-views so forgive me if I [ __ ] up
the pronunciation is it golovkin first
Canelo and that took me back
that's what pay-per-view boxing used to
be I'm not saying he didn't get [ __ ]
every once a while back then but it was
just dude there was [ __ ] forehead to
forehead just it was a war feeling each
other round respecting each other and
all that [ __ ] and then the usual
[ __ ] happened
you know how that [ __ ] lady sought
118 to 110 I mean Jesus I don't know
[ __ ] about boxing and I was like what
the [ __ ] and I loved how Roy Jones and
the [ __ ] in goes like I he goes I
love that it was a draw you know because
that means we get to see this again and
next time there's definitely going to be
a decision and I felt like I felt like
he was like they were like Roy don't
bring this up this is the Illuminati
script of boxing please don't bring this
[ __ ] up that's this whole [ __ ] thing
is that it was gonna be a draw if we had
any way to make this thing be a [ __ ]
draw so we could do it again but it was
great it was a great [ __ ] fight it's
I thought the love can clearly won the
fight I just thought he was backing off
the whole [ __ ] time and I know can I
have some big shots towards the end but
he love can just [ __ ] walk he ate him
all up he ate him up he just can't he
would back off her second you just come
back and then he would [ __ ] give him
you know if he took two he'd come back
and give him two I just thought you know
I don't know I agreed with you that that
[ __ ] guy who screams all the time
that guy is always screaming they have
him in the crowd so he can't hear
himself does he not have headsets on I
love that he yells every [ __ ] time I
don't know I thoroughly enjoyed it the
decision obviously stunk but I did not
feel that I got [ __ ] on my money I
feel like the fighters got [ __ ] and I
retweeted this rant that Teddy Atlas
went on and it was you know somebody has
to say so I just don't understand how
it's still that corrupt it's just
they've never liked who was weird like
Vegas was totally corrupt and totally
mobbed up and then they cleaned it up by
putting those corporations in there who
then [ __ ] you on everything including
the steak why can't they clean up boxing
can they get the mob out of this so the
corporation's can come over on the legal
side of stealing and [ __ ] people more
than they ever have maybe
the app I have no idea I don't
understand it but Teddy Atlas said I'm
gonna butcher it how he said it he said
those guys went in the ring and came out
less of who they were meaning that they
that you do permanent damage to yourself
I mean when they will break it down the
they will break him down the power shots
and all of that type of [ __ ] it's like I
was watching Rogen's recap of it with
Jim Norton and Rogan read some stats
where this guy he took okay you know
here's the blew his head he took a
hundred and eighteen punches to the
[ __ ] head I haven't taken 118 punches
to the head in my life my Boulder
brothers to beat the [ __ ] out of me all
the time but we knew you kept it to the
body that's why your father wouldn't see
it when he came home so but other than
that I mean it was it was great it was
everything that I knew that Mayweather
and McGregor wasn't gonna be and that's
why I didn't rent it and that's why I
spent my money on that
I still got [ __ ] but is Tommy Morrison
still alive okay I have to hit pause on
this cuz I gotta watch this [ __ ] he's a
relative a [ __ ] John Wayne in case
you didn't know um so he's a boxer back
in the day all right I gotta read some
of the [ __ ] here for this week I can't
see anything here doing this in my
[ __ ] living room we bought these
things when we yet another thing I had a
fix on this house they these [ __ ]
awful lights on the wall so we bought
these sconces these really fancy [ __ ]
things and the thing the fancy thing in
front of the light is so goddamn thick
that it always seems like it's on a
dimmer I probably should you just bought
a higher watt bulb I don't know this has
gotta be one of those moments for you
like why the [ __ ] am i listening to this
guy he's talking about the [ __ ]
lightbulbs in his living room I'm sorry
all right DNA testing at Ravens game you
know boy dear Bill I love the podcast
love you stand up a love F
for family thank you I have to stop
promoting that at my stand-up shows too
because I feel like a lot of people
still don't know the shows on so if you
get a chance if he give the show tell
your friends about it and everything
just so we can continue doing the show
would be awesome
he said I wanted to hear your opinion on
this very weird giveaway at Sunday's
Ravens game I'm a season ticket holder
for the Ravens and it's not unusual to
get a little freebies when you enter
stadium commemorative coins beer koozies
flags etc sunday is the home opener and
some company is giving away free DNA
tests so I guess this happened yesterday
free DNA test what are you trying to do
figure out if you're a [ __ ] human
being and it's not even some
ancestry.com type [ __ ] that could give
you some semi useful information you're
not getting any useful information from
ancestry.com they're doing what this
company's doing I don't know what
they're doing but they're not trying to
help you out do you really need to know
how much Scottish blood you have in you
you really need what so what you can do
what go out and go feel justified buying
a [ __ ] kilt you're not Scottish
you're a mutt the article I linked says
they're testing for four genes the test
offers insight into your mind body and
health is what they claim it seems like
this company just wants a bunch of data
and they figured that an NFL game is a
great way to get 70,000 mouths breathe
and [ __ ] morons that not part was me
70,000 people deep 70,000 people's DNA
all at once the company is also
partnered with the 49ers so testing
might come to San Francisco soon what
are your thoughts keep up the good work
and go [ __ ] yourself I think I know
exactly what this is in the future
people's DNA is going to be it's just
starting to become a revenue source the
way your phone number and all of this
other [ __ ] that they get from you at CVS
and all these [ __ ] places it was
another revenue stream where you were
buying shaving cream tampons whatever
the [ __ ] you were doing and then they
would get personal information from you
that then they could then sell to other
[ __ ] companies I think it is now that
they've exhausted
all of that they've now moving on to
fingerprints face recognition in DNA and
they're going to share this with
everybody and I know the robots are
coming I don't know how to I don't know
where this all lands I know that there's
talks in the future that human beings
could be meshed with robots if I had to
guess they're probably gonna get to the
point where with your DNA they can grow
another you and say well that's not
really you the real you is going to the
Ravens game so we can do all kinds of
Nazi doctors Nazi doctor esque type
experiments on this with the [ __ ]
robot before we release this to the
public that's where I think it's going
all right
and you know I don't want my twin adult
brother coming into this world at 51
years of age because I figure another
two years they'll probably start doing
it
and getting a [ __ ] you know bionic
arm put on as he's screaming and [ __ ]
pain cuz God knows they're not gonna use
[ __ ] anaesthetic because that that
[ __ ] DNA version you will be the
property of a corporation and we'll have
no rights to [ __ ] anesthetic why
don't I write sci-fi you know I did the
whole [ __ ] thing about how you had to
take a test and if you flunked the test
on the population control you just walk
into the ocean and now there's a movie
coming out about that I don't know maybe
I'm just not original maybe I should
start writing these [ __ ] things and
that sounds like a cool [ __ ] movie
right you have to go save yourself you
know do some [ __ ] creepy happy ending
where you're just staring there yourself
touching each other's face and
everybody's [ __ ] crying I don't know
you throw Will Smith in there somehow
it's a winner all right whiny fan
complaining all right howdy bill I'm a
four-year podcast listener and I saw you
live in San Antonio earlier this year I
think your layers guy and obviously at
your podcast
and I should go [ __ ] myself but I think
your Trump positions are kind of unfair
Oh God not another political [ __ ]
person he did call himself off for being
I think your Trump positions are kind of
unfair well then you think my Hilary
ones are fair all right god bless you I
know you're just a comedian I know you
have a lot of fans in the quote real
America oh there's the left talking down
to the right okay and so you have to toe
a line this is the classic I really hope
the person who wrote this is listening
sir you're and you are inventing all of
this in your head because you're upset
about something politically okay are you
mad at what I'm talking about about
Trump is that what this is you feel I
have to toe some sort of [ __ ] what
liberal line because I'm out here in
Hollywood but Trump is to my mind
obviously a dangerous guy I won't go
through my whole list of grievance
grievances but he thinks climate change
is a Chinese hoax supports white
supremacist and just this week through
the lives of 800,000 what way don't go
to make sure you didn't use any comments
eight million people who were brought
here as children into disarray I know
every president has skeletons but even a
liberal like me well is a Hillary person
can see this guy is nothing like w w or
George H dude when did I say I like this
guy I never did I never said that I like
the guy
I just said people freaking out about
him and losing their [ __ ] [ __ ] I
should have been more specific like
[ __ ] white people acting like the
needle in your life was going to change
that [ __ ] far all right by the way
you know if you really want to see a
bunch of skeletal I mean this election
was essentially two a.m. at a bar I mean
you had to go home with somebody right
probably shouldn't have listened
this [ __ ] guy thinks climate change
is a hoax fine
all right Hillary was all for bailing
out these [ __ ] banks in 2008 which is
exactly what the [ __ ] happened and all
these people who stayed in Florida
riding out the [ __ ] storm and
everybody's making fun of them and
saying how dumb they are for staying
there
they're probably upside down in their
house and unlike the bankers don't have
another house that they can go to yeah
evacuate the area and do what go with
half of the Florida and sit in a [ __ ]
Waffle House in Georgia and then what I
don't have enough gas money to get back
I love the complete lack of sympathy for
people that can completely [ __ ] in
2008 which Hillary was totally all about
she was also all about [ __ ] you know
ignoring the wishes of the people on the
Left who voted more for [ __ ] Bernie
Sanders according to this trial and
colluded with the Democratic Party to
ignore those votes in box Bernie Sanders
out and she just took the nomination and
now all of a sudden she's got the
[ __ ] balls to sit here and talk about
the Electoral College okay she's not a
good person either and I'm not saying w
is I told you I was done I wanna see W
me sorry Donald Trump I said I was done
with Donald Trump when he said that both
sides can take contributed to the
violence that he couldn't even get
himself to say that those Nazis might be
a little out of their [ __ ] minds the
neo-nazis I told you I was done with the
guy okay but you hate the guy so much
you're hearing what you want to hear all
right maybe I don't trash Trump enough
in this podcast but I don't feel that I
need to everybody at least in my
profession has a bit on how [ __ ]
stupid the guy is million dry mouth
talking about this [ __ ] so III don't and
for you to sit there you [ __ ] [ __ ]
after four years of listening my podcast
acting like I told some sort of line did
you ever listen to my [ __ ]
advertising I lose advertisers all the
[ __ ] time okay if I was towing some
sort of line I would read those things
like I was on [ __ ] Lawrence Welk hype
and Geritol I don't okay
I told a line as far as I say what the
[ __ ] I think is funny that's the line
that I am towing here sir
I'm sorry the guy that you wanted to
[ __ ] win didn't [ __ ] win
I know I know Trump's out of his [ __ ]
mind and I don't need you wagging your
[ __ ] finger at me give me a goddamn
[ __ ] lecture is if I don't understand
that this guy is [ __ ] up okay so why
don't you look at your I'll up your own
[ __ ] skirt it'd be a little more
even-handed
all you [ __ ] guys I mean I guess you
got a whine about Trump cause he's
actually the [ __ ] president of Jesus
Christ the [ __ ] pass I don't know
what the [ __ ] it is that Hillary gets is
is unbelievable
PS Hillary sucks that's all I get on
this side you know he says look man I
just think that despite what you're
saying about being comedian you do have
a platform [ __ ] you buddy
[ __ ] you you're not putting that on me
all right I can tell you this right now
dude
if you get your political information
from a [ __ ] stand-up comedian who
can't even read out loud you use this
thing to decide who the leader of the
quote free world is gonna be I can't
help you what am I supposed to do you
know what I would say to you send you
[ __ ] DNA into the Ravens anyways you
do have a platform and while I'd never
dare to tell you what to say I hope you
will consider what happens when you play
down the danger of his behaviors let me
ask you this sir what exactly would be
happening now if the other [ __ ]
bought and paid for
[ __ ] [ __ ] went in there what do you
think would happen what do you think
would happen huh
do you honestly
well she admits that global warming is
real what do you think would happen do
you think she's gonna do anything most
the most she could be and therefore is
eight [ __ ] they just wait him out
Al Gore in 1992 said that there has to
be a car that gets at least 100 miles a
gallon by the [ __ ] year 2000
something like that and just kept
delaying the project and delaying it and
delaying and delaying and delaying it
and then they were out of office and it
just [ __ ] went away there you go
so I don't know what to tell you I have
to tell you buddy
I always vote outside of the Democratic
and the Republican Party okay unless I
find somebody within them like a Bernie
Sanders who I feel will actually
hopefully make more people within those
bought and paid for [ __ ] groups I
don't know take a stand for [ __ ]
regular people I mean that's what I do
okay
I don't like Trump the guy makes me sick
to my stomach I think he's I absolutely
think the guy's [ __ ] racist but I
also think Hillary is the [ __ ] devil
and in a lot of ways we sidestepped a
bunch of other [ __ ] okay we walked into
a bunch of the [ __ ] with Trump but you
definitely sidestep too but come on man
everybody anybody with any remote sense
of intelligence knows that you know that
was the [ __ ] Bluebonnet bull all
right that wasn't the [ __ ] that
wasn't Alabama versus [ __ ] Clemson or
[ __ ] that was you know that was the
Holiday Bowl election all right actual
money base but I you know and I don't
know I don't know why you needed to send
me that dude you honestly think that I
want to see [ __ ] kids get sent out of
this country I don't I don't okay so
stop turning me into the [ __ ] you know
what it is do you know why this
country's [ __ ] out there's a guy who
can't read out loud that does a podcast
twice a week and I'm telling you that is
if we could just get him to politically
say what we feel I think we could turn
this country around we're taking callers
I said buddy actual money based on gold
hey Billy gold bollocks that'd be great
have some gold bollocks in that [ __ ]
diamond-encrusted pouch I was listening
to Rogen's podcast recently and he had a
guy called Peter shift on and he was
talking about gold money.com
this is basically a private gold reserve
where you can buy gold which is held in
a secure vault oh is it
listen you give us our money and we'll
have will hold your gold great so they
keep my cash and the gold so I gotta set
them a donkey to and using a prepaid
mastercard you can pay for goods and
services with your money backed by gold
or platinum if you'd rather buy that
well I would do that immediately or when
the dollar crashes effectively what the
bank's used to do before they sold the
foundations of our currency here is here
in the UK Gordon Brown sold all the
diamonds that backed sterling when the
bank [ __ ] the bed I don't know what any
of that means here in UK Gordon Brown
who's Gordon Brown was at a bank like
[ __ ] JP Morgan sold all the diamonds
that backed sterling when the bank's
shat the bed okay
so you got your money back as I was
saying I just this minute signed up this
sounds like commercial and I'll be
putting some money into it although not
all my money as it's always best to
diversify when you stash your saving I
think it is much better than Bitcoin as
it's actually based on something of
value I love you go [ __ ] yourself sir
why don't you just take your money and
go buy a gold coin why don't you just do
that why don't you take your paper and
go buy some gold and leave with the gold
rather than giving your money to this
[ __ ] person you're not gonna meet and
he tells you that he has God you know
this gold there he's basically doing
what they're doing with Fort Knox where
they say there's all this gold in there
and then there's rumors that it's
[ __ ] empty I like the direction
you're going in but I think you went out
of the frying pan into the fire with
that one grant I don't want to [ __ ] on
whatever that guy's doing because I got
your abridged version of it but um that
reminded me of that movie blow with
Johnny Depp's character gives him two
million dollars in cash and they give
him a book that says two million dollars
on it then he goes to jail he never gets
his [ __ ] money all right my
girlfriend's daughter is causing us to
break up is that a bad thing
Jesus Christ I mean you already dating
somebody that already has a kid so
that's gonna be re a hundred times
harder to make that [ __ ] work and
then the kid doesn't even like you so I
mean maybe she's doing you a solid here
hey Bill okay here we go so my girl and
I of seven years both work for the same
company and I was offered a better
position in Florida and she was also
offered a position as well now here's
where the daughter comes in and [ __ ] up
the flow yeah cuz she [ __ ] probably
wants to stay at her school
her daughter's 14 is just starting high
school and her Foods refusing to move
and her mother is going along with not
forcing her to move and is going to pass
her is going to pass in a position we
agreed I will not move down and get
things in order until she weight we
agreed I will move down and get things
in order until she gets there in four
years now for the past few weeks we've
been getting into more fights and her
reasoning for the fight is sit down for
this one bill
she says it's easier for me to leave
when she's mad she's fighting you
because it's easier for you to leave
when she's mad I think that's a dumbest
[ __ ] reason I've ever heard also she
keeps saying I'm going to go down and
find myself some black ass and end up
cheating on her while I'm there we'd
love to get your take on this situation
and get your insight on what I should do
thanks and pick up a [ __ ] drink you
[ __ ] [ __ ] I would say I'd say there's a
staggering lack of trust I think the key
here is to not get into an argument with
her is to just sit down and try and
discuss it with her and just say listen
we agreed that this is what I was going
to do and now what it is is you know I
think this is what happened what she did
was is she did what was best for her
daughter and she put herself with you in
second but she still sounds like cares
about you and the fact that you're down
there she's worried that you're gonna
leave and she misses you I think that
that's what's happening
so I would just ask her it's just some
like misdirected anger I you're actually
just saying that you miss me and you
love me is that what you're saying it we
could work through this and then if
you're really not gonna [ __ ] around
we're on her and you're really gonna see
it through then you want to be able to
just say listen I'll do whatever it
takes I'm gonna be there in four years
if you're not lying I think you ought to
be able to work your way through it and
I think this has less to do with the
daughter than it has to do with the fact
that she just misses you and she's
afraid that you're gonna find somebody
else down there evidently wherever you
moved where there's a bunch of black ass
down there that's what I would guess so
I you guys need to get on the same page
and you have an honest moment with
yourself before you [ __ ] slowly tear
the band-aid off either get the [ __ ] out
of it or totally commit to her I mean
seven years at this point why don't you
drop in a [ __ ] ring on her dad I shut
her up for a good couple of weekends it
won't shut her up permanently I can tell
you that right now oh I can tell you
some stories oh can I tell you so I can
hear a tale a tale of a married guy who
jumps through all the [ __ ] hoops and
still gets the evil Laden all right my
wife my wife is a who dear Billy butter
tits [ __ ] you I'm losing weight my wife
my wife decided to have an affair four
months ago
oh boy before I knew what was going on
she told me she didn't know if she
wanted to be married to me anymore and
that it was because I was too
controlling and by controlling she means
I told her as a stay-at-home mom I had
expectations I expected her to keep the
house clean and take care of our
children as we agreed when she quit her
job yeah I mean that which is a totally
fair ask you know but nowadays in this
world of hyper [ __ ] feminism not all
feminists are bed but the [ __ ] the
the god is great [ __ ] crazy ones
there yeah they would say that that was
sexist that you know why don't you work
all [ __ ] day and then come home and
also have the house clean you know I
mean I mean look if you got a bunch of
kids it can only be so [ __ ] clean but
the least you could do was order a pizza
right
anyways I would come home to her friends
being at the house and her drinking all
afternoon while Jesus Christ she's not
even making an effort this is what
happens when you draft in the first
round buddy
you know you get those second rounders
they they got some the [ __ ] proof you
know that says what happens when you
marry a 10th I'm assuming she's
good-looking if you're putting up with
this [ __ ] I would get home from work
after being gone 15 hours and have to
say something about how I felt that the
house was a wreck and there was no
dinner in sight it never seemed to
matter back in January we moved to
Denver from Atlanta thinking everything
would be better and she met this 25 year
old guy who she proceeded to sneak
around behind my back with and bring our
children around no way I'm 38 she's 35
we have two children and we've been
married for almost 12 years yeah dude
yeah this is a wrap yeah and now she
wants a divorce it plans to move this
kid into our home with our children oh
my god dude this is the worst person
ever I am beside myself with the thought
of the divorce and this punk kid living
with my children oh my god I know it
won't last but the fact is I don't want
my children to be around this piece of
[ __ ] let alone living in my house she
think this is she thinks this is
perfectly okay to put the kids and I
through this I do love her and would do
anything to save our marriage but the
truth is she is delusional at this point
and I guess I am too what do I do this
stopped us I know this is not my fault
because I busted my ass to build the
life she always dreamed of only for her
to think she can kick me out of it any
advice and/or the lovely Nia you could
give would be greatly appreciated thanks
and go [ __ ] yourself yeah man I mean
this is the things this is what can
happen to a guy
but you're not allowed to talk about
this on television are you never never
never you can talk about guys being
overbearing domestic violence all those
things that should be brought to light
but they will not talk about this you
watch dr. Phil talk about this you watch
him blame the guy
so she saying the reason that she sucked
his [ __ ] was because you weren't paying
enough attention to her you need to try
to pay attention more to her while she's
sucking his dick what do I do to stop
this I don't know at this point I would
be thinking about my kids and how I
could make this as look do this it's
what the [ __ ] she wants to do this is
what the [ __ ] she wants to do how you
make this as easy a [ __ ] transition
your [ __ ] divorce I can tell you this
I know you called her a [ __ ] here don't
ever say that to your kids because at
the end of the day it's still their
mother and you got a [ __ ] you know
you got to look the other way I don't
know dude this is this is outside my
[ __ ] realm I can tell you this dude
you [ __ ] 38 years old you sound like
a great [ __ ] guy I would just
whatever you got to do for your kids I
would do that her is a [ __ ] lost
cause all right and I would yeah I would
do that and I would start p90x and go
out and get yourself a [ __ ] beautiful
good-hearted [ __ ] woman I would have
me out maybe even if you have time I
would go to therapy and figure out how
the [ __ ] you ended up unless she's just
a total psycho like so you don't go out
and [ __ ] marry that again figure that
out but the [ __ ] I'm trying to marry you
off already Jesus Christ you you're just
getting out of something I don't know
dude this my head spinning over this one
cuz I'm putting myself in your shoes I
don't know what the
I would do oh man that's a rough one
some other [ __ ] guy going in telling
you kids to pipe down I mean jesus
[ __ ] christ
yeah I would I would I would talk to
somebody about this
way beyond my [ __ ] educational level
that's what I would do I hope you get
through this thing and what a [ __ ]
mistake she's making I can tell you that
but she the way you described it granted
only at your side of it she does not
sound like the prying a person that even
when she does [ __ ] it up she'll admit it
she probably still put it on you and but
you know what it'll all come out in the
wash and your kids are gonna know that
you're a [ __ ] good guy
so well geez Grogan can we can we end on
that I don't know I don't think so hang
on a second Nia okay my phone I thought
she could come on she can't just gotta
do mommy duty I gotta have it back on
more man I miss having her on here um
anyways that's the that's the podcast
for this week how about those dolphins
want to know top of the AFC East you
know
Patriots one in one in second place it's
still early Kansas City looking [ __ ]
tough what else Cowboys defense is in
shambles
Brett aren't called me or text me all
[ __ ] concerned about that but it's
still early it's still [ __ ] early
we'll see what's going on my beautiful
daughters crying downstairs so I'm gonna
go handle that [ __ ] and literally and
figuratively God knows that's it I'll
check in on you on Thursday
enjoy the Monday Night Football game
tonight and once again congratulations
to the Cleveland Indians 22 in a row I'm
you know obviously never saw that ever
that's in [ __ ] incredible
that's almost almost one in a month's
worth of games yeah built this 30 days
in a month and they almost play every
day yeah thank you Bill all right go
[ __ ] yourselves we'll talk to you on
Thursday